today the mat will show a vision for an
eco-friendly city of the future that
resembles a human termite colony the
powers that be want us all crammed
together eating bugs and hopped up on
drugs we'll talk about that today also
joe biden prepares to declare monkey pox
a public health emergency
but is it or is it an emergency only for
people who engage in certain specific
types of behavior plus a shocking poll
from 1997 reveals just how far we've
fallen with race relations in recent
times and in our daily cancellation a
reality show is under fire for not
featuring enough ugly people are ugly
people the new marginalized minority and
favored victim group i certainly hope so
all of that and more today on the matt
welsh show
[Music]
you've heard me talk a lot on this show
about how important it is to get your
kids away from the garbage that they're
teaching in our public school systems
marxism socialism critical race theory
and the trans agenda
now there are a lot of ways you can
protect your kids from these
not-so-secret leftist attacks you can
homeschool you can get them involved in
a religious community you can give them
uh the right books to read like my
best-selling children's book johnny the
walrus these things are all great and
you should do them but what if you
couldn't no one likes to talk about it
but we all will eventually die it's just
how life works and the end result is
always the same some of us however may
die sooner than others and we need to be
prepared for that possibility because if
we're not prepared if we haven't taken
the necessary steps to shield our kids
from aggressive attacks indoctrination
attempts coming from the left then we've
left them completely unarmed and
unprotected that's why you should take
five minutes to sit down tonight and
write a will that will ensure your kids
will be raised the way you would have
intended in the event that something
does happen to you lucky for you my
sponsors over at epic will make it
really easy to do epic will is an online
platform that costs less than your next
trip to target they can uh set you up
with a will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 dollars plus you
can save 10 you go to
and use offer code walsh again go to
epicwhale.com and use my code walsh
today
the architects of the new world order
are always searching for ever more
efficient ways of containing and
controlling and dehumanizing us
stripping our lives of beauty
destroying our freedom and treating us
like cattle to be herded and used as we
know the goal is to have us all living
in pods stacked up on top of each other
eating bugs owning nothing and having no
privacy they seek even to lay claim to
our inner lives our consciences
the complete human existence they
believe is one spent sitting in your
rented prison bunk eating your ration of
grasshoppers for the day numbed by
psychotropic drugs while wearing your
virtual reality headset to attend an
endless string of corporate diversity
seminars
millions of people are already living a
life that comes very close to this
utopian ideal but our overlords know
that there are still advances yet to be
made new and innovative ways of eating
our souls and making our lives even
drearier and uglier
enter the crown prince of saudi arabia
with a concept
that has been ominously dubbed the land
scraper the guardian reports the
promotional material is striking two
mirror-encased skyscrapers stretching
more than a hundred miles across a swath
of desert and mountain terrain providing
a future home for nine million people is
it the ultimate in hide in high density
living or or a grandiose science fiction
fantasy in short economist architects
and analysts are not quite sure so so
extravagant to saudi arabia's plan to
create an urban utopia that even those
working on the project known as the line
do not yet know if its scale and scope
can never be realized skeptics and
supporters alike were this week given
more insight into the extraordinary
ambition of the development the
centerpiece of the futuristic
neom site near the gulf of acaba when
the kingdom's crown prince mohammed bin
salman outlines central aspects of what
he intends to be one of the most
ambitious urban developments built in
modern times
now the concept will cost about a
trillion dollars to build and the hope
is that this idea can be exported to
many other countries including our own
to make cities more efficient and
eco-friendly you know to save the planet
and to finally
bring into being a real-life sci-fi
dystopia there have been a lot of
different visions for how this this can
be done many different people in
different countries have had ideas of
like what the cities of the future will
look like in order to save the planet
and um this is what this one's all about
here's a promotional video
explaining it a little bit more watch
for too long humanity has existed within
dysfunctional and polluted cities that
ignore nature
now a revolution in civilization is
taking place
imagine a traditional city and
consolidating its footprint
designing to protect and enhance nature
the line will be home to nine million
residents and will be built with a
footprint of just 34 square kilometers
and we are designing it to provide a
healthier more sustainable quality of
life
the lines communities are organized in
three dimensions
residents have access to all their daily
needs within five-minute walk
neighborhoods
and the line's infrastructure makes it
possible to travel end-to-end in 20
minutes with no need for cars resulting
in zero carbon emissions
by leveraging ai technology services are
autonomous saving you time and effort
designed by world leading architects the
line is 500 meters tall
200 meters wide
170 kilometers long
and housed within an elegant mirror
glass facade
intelligent solutions create efficiency
and year-round temperate micro-climate
with natural ventilation
energy and water supplies are 100
percent renewable
the line is designed as a series of
unique communities offering a wealth of
amenities providing equitable views and
immediate access to the surrounding
nature
oh well i mean as long as you'll have
equitable views because that's the kind
of view we all want isn't it you hike up
to the top of a mountain
look out at god's creation and say wow
the view up here is so
equitable
that's a very normal and human reaction
right
anyway the plan as you see is to build a
narrow 100 mile long mirrored prison in
which you can live and work and never
leave and then die
as others have pointed out it looks very
much
like a sleek and modern border wall of
sorts actually so how quickly we went
from no don't build the wall to build
the wall and live inside it and speaking
of living inside walls this plan appears
to have been inspired partly from sci-fi
dystopian films that the architects have
mistakenly taken as how-to guides but
then also partly from the living
quarters of household pests
what they've come up with is is an
exciting opportunity
for anyone who's ever dreamed of living
in a termite colony
it may seem like you know you'd have a
rather dismal existence inside this
thing surrounded on all sides all the
time by glass and steel totally cut off
from nature but at least you'll have the
entertainment of watching birds
constantly smash into the enormous
mirrored exterior walls same for any
other species of animals whose migration
pattern happens to intersect with the
human filing cabinet that they're
building
now
it may seem pointless to complain about
this it's in saudi arabia it's not here
actually it's not even in saudi arabia
it's nowhere this is a concept a plan we
don't know if they'll actually be able
to build it and if they do build the
thing it seems highly likely that the
experiment will fail in spectacular
fashion
mitigating the risk that something
similar would be attempted in this
country there are many ways that it
could fail
you know starting with the enormous
damage that a few well-placed suicide
bombers could do in a place like that
this is the middle east after all
not to mention the fact that you'd be
living in a literal transmission tube
for disease
in fact the whole thing seems like it
was designed by a virus but both the
biological and computer variety
because the entire structure is supposed
to run on computers and artificial
intelligence leaving its inhabitants
totally vulnerable to cyber attack by
the way what happens when someone takes
out the generators
in the giant glass rectangular prison in
the middle of the desert what then
of course the worst thing that could
happen though
is that the monstrosity is built
and it works
and no disasters befall it and all of
its inhabitants are kept satiated and
numbed enough that there are no
uprisings where the peasant class
violently overthrows the elites of the
rectangle eventually setting fire to the
whole thing and dancing around it as it
burns
if nothing like that were to happen
tragically
then perhaps eventually we would end up
with something similar here
either way
whether they try to force us into this
particular hellscape or they construct a
slightly different sort of futuristic
livestock stable for us
the fact is that this is the direction
that the powers that be wish to take us
and are taking us
so it's worth pointing out the problems
with this plan and any plan similar to
it
and by plans similar to it i'm including
modern day cities as they currently
exist
which in their construction are only
slightly less horrifying than the total
recall-esque concepts that people like
the crown prince of saudi arabia are
coming up with
and all of the problems
including the ones i've already outlined
can be summarized this way
this actually just a problem with
leftism in general
it does not take into account human
nature
this is one of the defining features of
the elites in society the globalist the
utopian is they do not account for or
understand human nature
both the good and the bad of human
nature
so let's start with the bad
human beings in our fallen state
are naturally disposed to
antagonism tribalism hostility violence
that doesn't mean that every human being
is a violent savage it just means that
humans have that natural capacity and
the more that you cram humans together
into tight living quarters the more that
you're going to bring this side out
and since everybody is living in such a
densely populated environment when the
violence does emerge as it so inevitably
will
the harm it inflicts will be
exponentially magnified
one violent psychopath by himself out in
the woods
makes a good villain in a horror film
but the violent psychopath living in the
city right on top of hundreds of others
of other people
is by far the greater danger
especially because he can now form
tribes gangs with other violent
psychopaths and pretty soon your
beautiful harmonious
sardine can existence has turned into a
dirty grimy bloody awful nightmare for
an example of this phenomenon see
any city anywhere
now that's not to say that the violence
and crime in the city and the violence
and crime that would turn the giant
rectangle into a glass prison of despair
is all due to people living too close to
each other that's part of it the bigger
part
is of course the breakdown of the family
the state the destabilization of
necessary social structures the
deliberate institutional effort to
undermine law and order etc
but these are all the work of the very
same people who are planning the utopian
cities of the future so those problems
are all sure to follow
but human nature is not all bad
thankfully
one of our nobler characteristics
is that we hunger for adventure
creativity independence
now there may be people who for whatever
reason for whatever perverse reason
enjoys cities but
everybody
feels at peace in nature everybody can
appreciate a beautiful lake or a stream
or a mountain
people go to cities for convenience for
job opportunities for bars and
restaurants and nightlife and so on they
don't go there for beauty
they certainly don't go there for peace
they don't go there to fulfill any of
the deeper longings of the soul
the ideal most whole and complete way to
live
is on land you own
in a house that is yours
where you can breathe fresh air
and enjoy at least a little bit of quiet
and solitude and have along with your
family
at least a semblance of independence and
self-reliance
but
the issue is that we're harder to
control and manipulate when we live like
that
which is why the powers that be wish to
usher us back
closer together
on property we don't own
living lives we don't control
packed into our stalls like so many
horses in a massive modernized barn
that smells only slightly better if
we're lucky
that's just no way to live
yet it's how they want us to live
which is why we should live any way
but that way
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the left has ruthlessly
infiltrated virtually every major
institution in america in an effort to
groom your kids into little libs that's
what they want them all to be you've
heard disney openly admit to pushing
lgbtq audiologies onto
into kids content and into their brains
more and more we're seeing crt classes
added to school as well even the
scholastic kids magazine you grew up
with they're involved too like nowhere
is safe america's school system has been
completely hijacked by the left and
guess what parents and upstanding
educators are fighting back that's why
prageru kids is here to help prageru
kids offers content that's no longer
being taught or celebrated in schools or
woke kids shows they teach kids about
responsibility hard work equality under
god freedom critical thinking truth
innocence all these things that our kids
need and values they need now more than
ever get tons of resources to watch at
home and in classrooms by downloading
the prageru app to your smart tv and
devices go to pragerukids.com right now
and enjoy their animated shows books and
magazines for kids most importantly
support prageru in their efforts to get
america back on track subscribe now and
don't miss prageru's incredible free
kids content visit
pragerukids.com today okay i wanted to
tell you about one thing this is not a
paid promotion uh it's not an ad the
daily wire is making me read but i do
want to tell you about some friends of
mine a group called sidewalk advocates
they've been doing
great work for many years uh when my
wife and i have been supporting them for
a long time they reach out to women
outside of abortion clinics
letting them know
about their options and the resources
that are available because as we know
what what drives the women into the
abortion clinics
is uh
even
you know in spite of all this talk about
pro-choice and choices and all that what
drives the women in is the feeling that
they have no choice there are no choice
there's no choice at all
their lives are hopeless unless they go
and get an abortion so the sidewalk
advocates reach out and let them know
that there are other choices there are
other options
um and they've saved many lives in the
process and now after row
you know the work is
if anything more important not less
more important than ever
but they need the resources to do what
they do which means money and uh right
now they're running a fundraising drive
and all donations will be tripled up to
250 000
that's for like the next week or so uh
my wife and i will be sending them a
check i'd ask you to consider it too if
you have it in the budget like i said
this is not a paid ad i just i believe
what these guys do we've supported them
personally for a while and um
uh if you want to do the same go to
sidewalk advocates.org check it out
donate
um
and i think we all need to be
pitching in to the extent that we can
uh for the battles ahead
all right
so following in the footsteps of the
world health organization it's expected
that joe biden will officially declare
monkey pox a public health emergency
this is uh from politico it says the buy
administration is expected to declare
monkey pox a public health emergency in
the coming days according to two people
with knowledge of matter the declaration
which is made by the department of
health human services would follow a
similar decision made last week by the
world health organization by designating
the outbreak in emergency hhs could then
take a slew of actions including
accessing uh new money and appointing
new
um personnel according to the law that
dictates how and when the federal
government can declare such an emergency
the hhs secretary is scheduled to horse
hold a press briefing on monkey pox
on thursday morning and they're going to
tell us more about it now
i can tell you that
i guess as we've learned a public health
crisis is in the eye of the beholder
monkey box is not a public health crisis
for me
i'm not worried about it at all
because i'm a married straight man
which means it's almost certain that i'm
not going to get monkey box
and in fact someone made this point on
fox yesterday as they were talking about
monkeybox
and uh it was very upsetting for for
some other people especially including
other people on the panel so there was
this debate about monkey pox and one of
the guests
um ned ryan dared to point out
that it's
this is a disease that almost
exclusively
affects gay men it's almost exclusively
gay men contracting and spreading it
another guest brad palumbo
was offended by this and uh so they got
into a back and forth and brad
thought he did so well in this exchange
that he actually posted the video
himself to twitter to show everybody
look at this look at this debate that i
won
well you watch for yourself and uh tell
me what you think here it is as for
monkey pox i think there's a pretty good
rule in life
uh don't attend gay orgies uh when you
look at the new england journal's report
of the fight how about anybody
ned come on man it's not about gay
go look at the new england journals
report that nbc news reported on on
friday in which of the 528 cases they
reviewed 95
were between sex between men i think we
actually have to have a serious
conversation about where this is coming
from when i'm done brad you can talk
instead of going crazy and declaring a
national pandemic when 3 000 people have
it right now it's insane
i don't know man you don't have to be
gay to get monkey pox and uh you don't
have to be bigoted when you talk about
treating something that is that easily
spread it's not big yeah it is this is
science kennedy ninety-five percent of
the cases from the new year
brad we have 372 doses the united states
in denmark where the the smallpox monkey
pox vaccine is manufactured they were
ready to go but uh because this has
been an issue for more men in the gay
community it seems like it has been
lower on the priority list
brad yeah look ned is right he says that
monkey pox right now is mostly affecting
gay men the problem is that public
health wise not going to orgies in
general is a good policy to not get
sexually transmitted diseases 100 and so
we have to be really careful we saw with
the aids crisis with the hiv crisis
about how certain communities or certain
gay people will be stigmatized over
something that lots of people do and
we've got to be careful about that and
that kind of i will use the term bigoted
language that makes it seem like the
only people that get this are from one
group of americans hey guess what gay
men also have friends and family members
and colleagues and this is not just
transmitted through sexual activity it's
transmitted through close contact so you
don't fight diseases i'm glad brad
brought up hiv aids you don't fight
diseases by
caricaturing the people who get them or
who get them at one point in time
fox news ladies and gentlemen
so you have one guest ned who makes the
absolutely correct point that this is a
disease circulating almost exclusively
among gabe yes it's well it's not just
gay men yeah it's like only 97 or
something okay
um that's almost exclusively and then
everyone else in the bed okay come on
man that's bigoted they had the chance
to explain why it's bigoted and they
couldn't explain it and i just love it
when these people bring um aids up as if
it helps support their point
right so they they bring up
hiv as a way of of supporting this idea
that we shouldn't like highlight the
fact
that this is circulating
mostly among gay men well no a that's
that's
the the aids crisis and the way that it
was treated especially early on and is
still treated in fact
is a perfect example
of why the messaging
should be very specific about who this
primarily impacts
because
with with aids i mean i can remember
being in elementary school
i remember this vividly actually
learning about aids in elementary school
and being terrified like traumatized by
it because what we were told
is that anyone can get aids it can
affect anyone it doesn't matter it's not
it's this is not a gay thing it affects
anybody
and that's what they claimed it's like
they made it seem like you'd just be
walking on the street and and oh i got
aids
but that was never the case
yes it's theoretically possible to
contract hiv other ways there are us
there's maybe a small small portion of
people that have contract of
heterosexual non-drug users who've
contracted it's very very small
vast majority of hiv transmission was at
the time
has always been and still is among gay
men in particular and then second place
would be intravenous drug users
and what the messaging on hiv should
have always been is that if you're
not participating in gay sex and if
you're not an intravenous drug user you
really don't need to worry about this i
mean the list of things you should worry
there's there's going to be about
there's about 5 000 other things that
make the list before you get to aids
because that's just the truth
and the people who are participating in
the high risk activity ought to know
that it's a high-risk activity
and if you're going around having random
gay sex with a bunch of different men um
the fact that
this activity puts you uniquely
makes you uniquely vulnerable to things
like hiv and now monkey pox that's a
fact you should know
and then maybe it'll make you stop and
think like oh wait a second this is
maybe this is risky maybe this is
dangerous maybe i shouldn't be doing
this
chad felix green uh writer for the
federalist has screenshots that he
posted twitter a couple days ago
of uh just this is one
guy talking about how he contracted
monkey
and the user goes by the username babe
the pig boy so we kind of know what
we're about to get into here
he's a pig i mean by his own
by his own labeling
and the story is disgusting and graphic
but but i think it's worth reading so
he says hi so i have monkey pucks not
fishing for any sort of sympathy but
since i'm already known for being pretty
unabashed on the internet i figured i'd
give it an honest account of how i got
it and how my symptoms manifested to
hopefully educate anyone curious so
strap in
uh
i finally got back into the swing of
things and attended a friend's birthday
orgy
well
just
[Music]
hopping right into it so i attended a
friend's birthday orgy the fact that he
says that with no explanation
like that's a normal thing that we would
all oh a birthday orgy of course
well you know like people do on their
birthdays they have orgies
then when you get back into the swing of
that you know i'm getting warmed up a
little bit attend a couple orgies here
and there
so i finally got back into the swing of
things and attended a friend's birthday
orgy saturday the 9th i'd been watching
the news on monkey pox but the general
feelings on it really were and still are
developing by the day so i nor anyone
else was especially worried
uh especially since there have only been
two confirmed cases in the entire county
and the host of that group was a good
friend and a nurse so i trusted their
judgment and still having the event
happen oh that's a good that's good news
right this is a medical professional
who's having a birthday orgy
it was a great time i think i came into
sexual contact with somewhere in the
ballpark of 15 to 20 different men
so i attend the orgy have a great time
i don't even know if i can read this
next part but let's just say that he
is saying that he consumed
a large amount of human waste product
um and then he continues and he went
home drunk and uh et cetera et cetera
and then
the next day he had sex with some more
guys
and then he got monkey pox
who could have guessed who could have
guessed after all that you'd come down
with the disease i mean this is at least
at least it gave us permission not to
have sympathy for him because uh don't
worry babe the pig boy i have zero
sympathy for you whatsoever
but we're on the same page there so
that's good
and then he ends up by saying my two
cents it's reductive to tell gay people
to not have sex it didn't work in the
early days of aids and clearly it's not
working now but do your best to make
educated choices check your county's
case numbers frequently and if you can
avoid groups and anonymous encounters
yeah check the case numbers before
heading out that orgy or you drink human
waste product um
yeah just you know before you go out and
drink the urine of uh 15 different men
just check the case numbers be
responsible about it he says
this whole idea that it doesn't work it
doesn't work to tell people
what do you mean it doesn't work
no no no net uh
whatever you got whatever your name is
babe the pig boy
in fact it does work like to refrain
from that activity it does work
actually if you refrain from all the
activities that you just described
it is it will very effectively shield
you from any number of diseases
including monkey pox and a bunch of
other diseases that i'm sure you
probably have
so it definitely works
what you're saying is that it doesn't
work when someone tells you to control
yourself
but no no that's that's not something
not working it's not like the plan
there's no problem with the plan it's a
good plan
um the plan is like don't behave like an
animal okay
and going out and having sex with 20
random people and then more people the
next day you're behaving like an animal
that's not even human behavior
so that's the plan and if you are
if you have an issue with the plan that
that's that's a problem with you
that's a character problem and a really
severe one
actually
so there are a lot of stories like this
and we know actually that um
the this monkey pox's current outbreak
can be traced back to
gay bath houses and orgies in europe
and the fact that this all took hold
especially during pride month
is not a coincidence either
um
now
it's true
that anyone who attends orgies or has
sex with a bunch of random strangers is
vulnerable
but the other fact
that even fewer people want to say
is that this kind of behavior is more
common in the gay community than it is
among straight people it just is
okay straight people aren't going to
orgies
they're they're not
like i've never known i i've nev i've
never encountered
a heterosexual person who's been to an
orgy
and you know why it's almost by
definition
if you're straight then you don't want
to be sexually involved
with a group of people that will
inevitably include other men so just
like by definition if you're a straight
person you're not going to orgies
that's same for straight women
but here's the thing if you if you want
to pretend
that gay and straight people are equally
as likely to attend orgies and equally
as likely to have random sex with
multiple strangers in the same day okay
if you want to pretend and you are
pretending but let's pretend for a
moment
um fine actually
then can we just agree to condemn all
such behavior by all people i'm fine
with that compromise
babe the pig boy here is uh is a gay man
who has a gay orgy but
if if he had been
a straight man or straight woman at an
orgy doing all the things he said there
then i would condemn it just as much
absolutely
and i would also say this is animalistic
like barbaric
savage behavior
you're it's it's you're not acting
acting like a like a decent civilized
human being
so gay or straight i would absolutely
say so if if that's the compromise we
can arrive
at which we can arrive then i am that
i'm fine with that
is that what we're doing now can we just
condemn across the board
all reckless
sexual activity
any form of having sex with strangers
especially in groups but but even
individually one at a time
like whether you're having your orgy all
at once
or in succession with with a bunch of
different random strangers you know at
different points in the same weekend or
same month or whatever however you're
doing it you shouldn't be
i'm fine with that message
and i'm fine with going even farther
than that which i think we should
in shaming this kind of behavior this
reckless sexual behavior
shaming it
um and putting the same kind of shame on
it that we put on
like murderers honestly
because it is it's it is nearly
murderous behavior
you know you're doing this and you could
be spreading diseases you could be
killing people it's like you just don't
care because you want to get your
you know
you want to have your fun
it is hyper
uh
selfish narcissistic
nihilistic destructive behavior
and if we can keep shame and scorn on it
on anyone who engages in this kind of
stuff
good good with me
absolutely
all right um
the university of kentucky swimmer riley
gaines has been
speaking out
about this is according to daily wire by
the way speaking out about university of
pennsylvania swimmer leah thomas a
biological male
and stated that when the college women
competed against thomas at the ncaa
championships they were not forewarned
that thomas would be sharing the locker
room with them and undressing in front
of them so gaines spoke with tucker
carlson
um and was talking about
at first just the atmosphere fear at the
championships
which happened at georgia tech a couple
of months ago she said um
she said people just weren't talking
about it and so we get to the ncaas and
it was at georgia tech and so we get
there and the environment is nothing
like i've ever seen before it was so
almost edgy like people didn't really
know what to say who to say what to or
how to feel
and from here we'll go to the clip where
she tells the the rest of the story what
happened at the event and especially in
the locker room so let's listen to that
and then that night we watched leah
thomas win a national title and blow all
the other females completely out of the
water
and that next day we came back and the
mood had shifted to where people were
mad
the girls you know there were tears
these poor 9th and 17th place finishers
who missed out on being named an
all-american
there's extreme discomfort in the locker
room there's you know kind of these
grumbles is he wandering around the
women's locker room
yeah
when and that's not something you know
we were forewarned about which i don't
think is right in any means um changing
in a locker room with someone who has
different
parts
so they just set a dude loose in your
locker room and didn't tell you exactly
and so i feel like to have that kind of
forced upon us so not only were we you
know forced to race against a male we
were forced to to change in the locker
room with one
and so
it's just this feeling of like
what is happening like honestly like
is this really happening like this is
crazy
uh
so there's a story that she tells there
and again that's uh riley gaines
who
should be commended first of all for her
courage and speaking out about this
and the story she tells about the locker
room that to me is by far
the the bigger scandal
um the the more important aspect of this
whole story of of leah thomas and men in
general invading women's sports um the
fact that they're forced into the pool
with a man and and the man is stealing
medals and opportunities and all that
that of course is terrible and insane
but even worse is that they're made to
share the locker room
with the guy
just having their privacy
and their dignity
really taken from them
and yet that very often is treated like
um
you know
like not not as much of a concern as
what's happening in the pool what's
happening with with sports
and that's one thing that stuck with me
i thought was interesting
when in uh my film was a woman when we
talked to
one of leah thomas's teammates
and i asked her about the locker room
situation it was the same kind of thing
yeah thomas is in the locker room he's
getting changed and
same thing she said there's like no
conversation about it no discussion
about that
even when they brought in when uh when
university of pennsylvania brought in
the lgbt activists and counselors to
lecture the women
and tell them that hey if you've got a
problem with this
you need to go seek counseling no the
guy who's claiming to be a woman
and you know wearing the one-piece
bathing suit he doesn't need to see a
council you do if you have an issue with
it
but even then
the the locker room part of it wasn't
even talked about
she said in fact that um
you know the other women on the team
most of them didn't want to say anything
at all because they were afraid of the
backlash
but even the women who did speak out
uh they they were focused on the sport
part of it and not the locker rooms
which i just thought was was interesting
there's another point i want to make too
which is when you hear a story like this
these men go into women's locker rooms
we talk about it so much
but you very often hear from people on
the right
that hey
you know what the women who are who are
subjected to this it's up to them to
speak out and if they're not going to
speak out then i'm washing my hands of
it there's nothing i can do you know
sort of putting the onus on the women on
the girls who are in these situations
to say something about it and i agree
that we do need to call on everyone to
have courage and the closer you are to a
situation like this
um the more of a responsibility you have
to speak out
but it just seems really cowardly to me
on the part of some conservatives who
say i'm not going to say anything about
it the women aren't pro this is on them
especially as a man
right if you're a man you should be
you should have a drive to protect women
like to put it on a bunch of college
girls
to stand up against the guys that are
going into the locker rooms
what kind of man are you
is that would that be your attitude if
you were actually in a place and uh you
you saw a man about to walk into a
there was a man about to walk into a
woman's locker room would you say well
that's up to the women in there to
figure it out not me
if your daughter your wife is in there
would you say well they're gonna have to
they gotta stand up for themselves
i certainly hope not
i hope you would realize that it's your
responsibility as a man to step up
yes men should protect women i
understand that that is
um
considered an outmoded way of thinking
but i don't care
that's the reality it's the truth
so no i'm not just i'm not just going to
leave it to
girls in college and in high school to
be the ones to fight this thing out
wow they don't do it then nothing i can
do
that to me is a lame excuse
all right here's a fascinating
poll um highlighted by michael moynihan
of vice news and but this is a poll from
1997.
and this is when i was in like fifth or
sixth grade um and this is what the
polling data on race relations said
back in 1997. the article says nearly
nine out of ten black teenagers said
racism has little impact on their
day-to-day lives according to a time cnn
poll released on sunday the survey also
found more than half of all teenagers 62
percent of blacks 58 whites believe
racism is a big problem asked about
racism in their own lives 89 of black
teenagers said racism was a small
problem or not a problem at all
now you see that
and
at first it's kind of shocking because
it's unthinkable
that a poll like that would have similar
results today
you just you can't imagine a poll of
black teenagers 2022 and it comes back
that 90 percent are saying that racism
is not a problem we're only a small
problem in their day-to-day life
yet for those of us who lived through
the 90s it's actually not surprising at
all
because race was not an issue in the 90s
like it is now
i'm not saying it was perfect
okay and i made this point on twitter
and there are a lot of people that
respond and say what are you talking
about what about the rodney king riots
and what about oj and all this
yes all that happened
we're not saying that it was perfect
that there was perfect harmony that we
were living in a post-racial utopia no
one is saying that that's never going to
happen it's impossible
um what i'm saying is that in the 90s
that's when we got the closest to
racial harmony
that we've ever been
and we've been going backwards ever
since
which isn't to say that it was perfect
but we got as close as we're going to
get
9 out of 10 black teenagers in the 90s
saying that racism does not affect their
daily lives that proves the point
and again doesn't surprise me because i
was a kid in the 90s and i could
remember that this just was not it's not
that race never came up but it wasn't
this overriding
concern it wasn't suffocating everyone
and you could tell jokes and there were
you know and you could just
kind of live your life and and you
didn't have racial issues constantly
shoved down your throat
and there was not this focus
even in the school systems
on convincing kids you know if you're a
black kid well convincing them that
you're oppressed you're a victim
there was a little bit of that not
nearly like there is today
there wasn't nearly as much white guilt
foisted on the the white kids well if
you're a white person then you're
automatically a racist
you have to beg forgiveness for what
your ancestors allegedly did
so compare that to uh today i couldn't
find this exact question asked in the
last year or two but you could piece it
together from other questions there was
a gallup poll in 2021
[Music]
showing how many black versus white
americans say that race relations are
good
either somewhat or very you know
only 33 of black said that we have good
race relations in america in 2021 43 of
whites
in 2001 that number was 70
for blacks 62 for white
so 20 years ago black people in this
country according to the polling had a
better view of race relations than even
white people did
but a majority of everyone agreed that
race relations are pretty good
um
there was another question is racism
widespread this is now 2021.
84 of black adults said yes it is 59 of
white
so 90 of black teens in the 90s said
racism had little or to no impact on
their daily lives
which which means we can assume that
they didn't think that it was widespread
if it doesn't have any impact on your
day-to-day life then it's not as
widespread
but now nearly as many black americans
say that it's a widespread problem what
this means is that those you know we're
talking about black teenagers versus
black adults
so those teenagers growing up in the 90s
said well you know it's not that big of
a deal it doesn't affect my everyday
everyday life
since then
they've been convinced
otherwise
and that's because there has been a
concerted effort on the left
to
destroy all of the progress that had
been made
and to take us backwards
they realize that racial strife and
disharmony is uh better for them easier
to exploit
all right
what else we got here
here's uh
one quick thing before we get to the
comment section from the daily wire it
says dallas cowboys owner jerry jones
issued an apology on tuesday after using
what has been dubbed the m word that's m
amends and uh
or as in [ __ ] but you can't that's
what you can't say anymore to refer to
little people during a tribute to a team
executive who recently died the remark
drew the criticism of many including a
call for a public apology from the
little people of america
uh jones did apologize that earlier
today i made a reference which i
understand may have been viewed as
offensive i apologize jones made the
controversial references while sharing
memories about former cowboys scouting
director larry lacewell who served
during the team's three super bowl wins
in the 90s
um
and jones said quote i'm going to get me
somebody a [ __ ] to stand up there with
me and dress him up like lace and think
lace is still out there hold helping at
practice with us
okay so i don't so was was lisa a [ __ ]
then
i don't know i don't quite say but but
he said he said [ __ ] and that's and he
has to apologize for that what is what
term are you supposed to use that's the
other thing i'm wondering as i look at
this i guess
little people little people is that i'm
being told in my ear
i i see i don't first of all i don't
understand how is that less effect
little person
how is that less offensive than [ __ ]
doesn't little person sounds kind of
like doesn't little person sound
patronizing
you're saying to the [ __ ] oh look at
that little person
to me that seems more offensive
that makes me uncomfortable saying that
and so i'm gonna say [ __ ]
and you know because it's me speaking i
get to decide what i say i see when i
speak
i speak based and i use the words that
make sense to me
and that i'm comfortable using
i know the response is well but these
other people aren't comfortable with it
okay but they're not the ones talking i
am
you can use whatever words you want
i'm not going to use that word because
it just seems weird to me
and no one has explained like what
exactly is wrong with [ __ ]
what is what what is what's the inherent
quality of the word [ __ ] that makes it
offensive can you anyone explain it to
me
it's just been decided randomly because
this is what this is what they do this
is part of this is what the pc police do
this is one of their this is one of
their um
this is their mo it's just to go along
and kind of like just randomly change
the the labels for things oh that label
doesn't work anymore that's expired it's
past is expiration date we got a new
label now that we use
well why what makes it expire it just is
that's it
sorry not gonna do it can't do it
uh let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
you know no one likes to spend money on
their cars you buy it you drive it you
want to run forever with this car
maintenance-free unfortunately that's
just not the way things work snap out of
it get out of fantasyland okay cars
require upkeep the same way your house
requires upkeep the good news is that
you can maintain your car for less when
you shop for auto parts at rockauto.com
see chain stores have different price
tiers for professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers but rockauto.com's
prices are the same for everybody and
they're reliably low rockauto.com is for
everybody and not just it doesn't
require memberships or logins or
anything like that rockauto.com has been
in the auto parts business for 20 years
they're family owned their goal is to
make auto parts available and affordable
to keep you safe on the road they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet so whether it's for your
classic or daily driver get everything
you need in a few easy clicks delivered
right to your door the rockhotter.com
catalog is remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices you prefer
amazing selections reliably low prices
all the parts your car will ever need go
to rockauto.com get brakes shocks carpet
wipers uh headlights mirrors mufflers
lug nuts everything at rockauto.com and
be sure to write walsh in their how did
you hear about us box so they know that
i sent you
tai mai shu says matt claims to defend
the family while in the past criticizing
olive garden does he not know that when
you're here your family
well your family in the same way that
cinderella i guess was family with to
her stepmom
because that's how they treat you at
oliver they treat you terribly
you know all the the service is bad
everyone's surly in a bad mood
they send you off to some table that's
not even clean
last time with olive garden i sat down
the table was filthy
i said could someone clean the table why
don't you clean it
it tossed me a mop in a bucket
somebody said while you're at it go go
back in the kitchen we need some help
back there too
um
let's see
yoda says
matt what do you think of men
cross-dressing for halloween looking
forward to seeing you with blush cheeks
and nine-inch heels this october 31st
cheers and sweet baby gang for life well
obviously you're banned from the show
for that even asking the question
i take uh issue with the premise of the
question
men shouldn't be doing anything on
halloween at all
men should not be dressing up you
shouldn't be going to halloween parties
okay you stay home
kids knock on the door and ask for candy
then you open the door and you give that
candy that's all you do that's what
grown men should be doing on halloween
um
another comment says matt after your
response to carlson's marriage and life
advice yesterday the comment section
seemed overwhelmed with comments from
young men who feel marriage is not worth
it due to a combination of terrible
family court laws the majority of
divorce divorce is being initiated by
the woman and the quality of women
generally this seems to be a common
sentiment among young men on the right
and i've rarely heard it addressed i'm
concerned that we will not get very far
without strong families could you please
give us your thoughts on their concerns
thank you
well i'd say a couple of things first
the concern is not baseless right it's
not unreasonable it's true that the
family courts are stacked against men
it's true that there are a lot of
low-quality women out there there are
also a lot of low-quality men i would
say that it's about equal as far as that
goes that brings me to the point
which is
what's your other option
if not marriage
so i may agree with you
that these concerns are valid
but
then what
you you stay away from marriage because
you don't want to get hurt and then what
do you do
are you going to run off to the woods
and become a hermit fishing and hunting
and writing the next great american
novel
if so more power too that sounds like a
great plan i wouldn't just try to
dissuade you at all go do that
are you going to live a life of celibacy
become a monk or something live
you know enter the religious life again
more power to you
but that is not what most men are doing
most of the men who lodge this complaint
are not going off to the woods to be
hermits they're not entering religious
life
and and becoming celibate
so what do they do
they are not availing themselves by
their option
and they're still normal men who desire
the companionship of a woman that's a
normal
male desire
it's a good thing
and so if they're not going to get work
towards marriage they end up
watching a lot of porn
maybe having random hookups
where they can get them but mainly it's
the porn
you see the problem now you've become
exactly the kind of low-quality person
that you're worried about
you're exactly the kind of low-quality
person that you're accusing the women of
being and saying this is the whole
reason i can't
so you're part of the problem
and though you've avoided the potential
heartache of divorce instead you've
guaranteed a life of loneliness
rejection isolation and all the rest of
it
so yeah if you go out and you try and
you get married
or you even you you first you have to
it's not like you just walk outside and
say okay i'm married you gotta find
someone you gotta go through the whole
process and there are many ways that
could go wrong and there are many ways
you can get your heart broken
um and if things go really really badly
it could destroy your whole life that's
true
that's the possibility that's the
potential that's the risk there is risk
involved
and because you're worried about that
risk you're worried about that
possibility
you embrace what is guaranteed to be a
miserable lonely life
doesn't make any sense to me
and why are you embracing it you're
embracing it out of fear out of anxiety
you know because of the possibility that
things could go wrong that's no way to
live can't live that way
you can't make your decisions that way
especially such fundamental decisions
such fundamental life decisions cannot
be made based on fear which is what
you're talking about right
it's not like there are no good women
out there
i'm i can tell you they exist
i'm married to one
um and she's not the only one i didn't i
didn't take the only one and now they're
all off the market
there are plenty of good women out there
just like there are plenty of good men
the fact that there are a lot of
low-quality people in general that's a
cultural problem
what you have to ask yourself is are you
going to contribute to that problem or
be part of the solution
and are you going to take the risk
and shoot for a a uh
a happy fulfilled life
or are you gonna give up on it before
you've even tried
well we just hit another historic
milestone in the company now i'm not
talking about us closing in on 1 million
daily wire plus subscribers or selling
over 70 000 jeremy's razors i'm of
course referring to what is a woman
finally getting enough critic reviews to
earn a 100 fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes that's right a whopping five
whole critics have now found the time
encouraged to actually review one of the
most watched and talked about movies of
the summer and all five have loved it so
see the film audience and audiences and
five critics are raving about and you
can do that by becoming a daily wire
plus member
and if you do that you can stream what
is a woman and get 35 percent off of
your membership when you sign up today
go to dailywireplus.com also tune in
tonight to catch an all-new episode of
daily wire backstage where you'll your
favorite daily wire hosts come together
to discuss the news of the day you can
join me ben shapiro michael knowles
andrew clavin god king jeremy boring at
7 p.m eastern on the daily wires youtube
channel or at
dailywireplus.com see you there now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
we end today with something rather
exciting it's uh not often that i'm out
ahead of the progressive curve i rarely
get somewhere before the woke bandwagon
arrives
but that seems to be the case this time
there is this week controversy and
outrage over the netflix reality show
love is blind
now for those with iqs above 75 that
have prevented you from watching a show
like this the basic premise as i
understand it is that contestants are
locked in isolation pods where they meet
other contestants by talking to them
through a wall
and they then i guess select which
disembodied voice they like the most
they talk some more to that person then
they get engaged before the big reveal
where they actually meet in person
at which point they're instructed to
fight to the death with their bare hands
now that would actually be a much better
show um in this one they uh they instead
get married and then as soon as the
cameras turn off they get divorced
a true fairy tale romance
now there have actually been multiple
controversies around this show recently
the first is a lawsuit from a contestant
on an earlier season because they've
done multiple seasons of this show
because that's the sort of interest
there is in this content because we're
surrounded by morons and the contestant
alleges that producers starved him
deprived him of sleep
and forced him to get drunk all of which
makes the show sound way more
entertaining than it actually is but
that's not the controversy that matters
here the bigger outrage is over the fact
the show only features physically
attractive people i'm proud to say that
i spearheaded this woke backlash in a
youtube video we put out at the
beginning of the month where i reacted
to reality show trailers including one
for love is blind that was the first i'd
ever heard of love is blind and upon
seeing the commercial i immediately
pointed out this glaring flaw in the
plot everyone on the show appears to be
like a solid seven or eight and this
means there is nothing at stake
nothing on the line all the contestants
end up with attractive people
to give the show some suspense some
comedy some tragedy
you need to throw a few michael moores
into the mix
there should be a scene where a highly
attractive woman falls in love with a
man behind the wall
gets engaged
and the big reveal happens and she
recoils in horror
when a character from the star wars bar
scene walks out
now that would be great television
matching supermodels with
ripley's believe it or not displays
i would sit down and watch a show like
that i would take the hit to my iq to
watch that show
admittedly the wolf criticism of love is
blind is not quite the same
both me and the left are upset that
there are not ugly people on the show
but they're upset for a slightly
different reason for them the problem is
the lack of body diversity and inclusion
on the show
the backlash became severe enough that
one of the show's hosts vanessa lachey
who i assume is married to the you know
the guy from whatever backstreet boys
addressed in an interview with insider
claiming that um
there are no fat or ugly people on the
show because they're simply too insecure
to appear
there was like self-selection she said
but the mob
isn't buying that excuse buzzfeed took
her to task saying this is what they
wrote in their article if you've watched
love is blind you've probably definitely
noticed that the group of contestants
who make it to air don't reflect body
diversity like at all in a recent
interview with insider vanessa tried to
explain why the show doesn't embrace
body diversity in any real way her
answer was
not great in response to being asked
about the show's lack of body diversity
uh vanessa says she sometimes thinks
certain contestants don't make it past
the pods portion of the show
because uh they can't fit inside of it
that's actually not what you said
because they're they're
insecure so if i'm reading this right
vanessa vanessa's reason why the show
doesn't include diverse bodies in its
cast is because some contestants are
simply too insecure about their bodies
to appear on the show something tells me
we might be getting a clarification for
vanessa in the future regarding her
comments or maybe not either way we'll
see if love is blind goes in more
diverse directions casting wise when it
returns for its third season time will
tell
well if nothing else we can agree that
buzzfeed continues to feature great
writing and important journalism
huffington post isn't buying vanessa's
excuse either they write love is blind
has yet to prominently feature a
contestant who is plus size visibly
disabled or older or older than 40 which
seems odd since the concept of the show
is to fall in love with someone's
personality
rather than their physical appearance
now of course
the real reason that the show only has
attractive people the reason that most
shows only feature attractive people uh
this current show that you're watching
is an exception
the reason is that viewers prefer to
watch attractive people hence the term
attractive
this is doubly the case if the show
revolves around love and romance
people may watch a show like my 600
pound life but they probably wouldn't
watch my 600 pound wedding
well they might watch that but for very
different reasons then they watch the
typical reality dating show and that's
about all that needs to be said about
this
but i'll say more anyway
because there's one more point i think
that needs to be made huffington post
says that the point of the show
is for people to fall in love with
personality rather than physical
appearance
but the idea that you can love somebody
for their personality totally apart from
their appearance is a myth okay it's a
popular myth it's one that my generation
in particular was fed early and often
but it's a myth
of course you shouldn't and really can't
love somebody entirely for their looks
but their looks are an important part of
the package it's part of who they are
it's what draws you to someone
especially early in the relationship but
even as you grow together and you get to
know each other on a deeper level still
their appearance their body their
physical look and presence will remain
extremely important
your body is not just some sort of
meaningless shell which contains your
personality and your truer essence
your body is who you are
you're more than your physical body okay
you're not you're not merely your
physical body but you are also your body
it really is not possible
therefore to
love someone and not love their body
because their body is them
this distinction between looks and
personality doesn't even make sense
your personality
it is what makes you as a person
different from other people
that includes your body your face your
physical appearance and mannerisms all
of that is part of your personality
because it's part of your person
it's what makes you you and not somebody
else
this is actually an important point for
two reasons neither of which have
anything to do with reality shows the
first is that people who really buy into
this appearance doesn't matter idea are
more likely to get married and then
completely let themselves go
transforming very quickly into a
physical specimen quite different from
the one that their spouse married
now obviously we all change over time
gradually as we get older but
we still have a responsibility in a
marriage to take care of ourselves
we should want to be physically
attractive to our spouses
it's quite selfish to throw that all to
the wind
and gorge ourselves with abandon
the second and deeper point is that our
culture is constantly trying to separate
the body from the person
as if these are two distinct things
in its most extreme iteration of course
we're told that a person with a man's
body can still be a woman and we're told
straight men can and should date these
trans women because though they have the
physical appearance of men they're
really women deep inside
but this is incoherent
as straight men we're attracted to women
not just for their bodies but their
bodies are certainly a significant
appeal it wouldn't make any sense at all
it would be totally unintelligible to
say that you're attracted to women but
you're neutral about their bodies
their bodies are what make them women
for all of us our bodies are what make
us who we are
this is
you know i think this conversation has
certainly gotten more esoteric than was
necessary for discussion about a netflix
dating show but i just go wherever the
path takes me
and now it takes me to a place where i
must say that
love is blind is not canceled
it's the critics of love is blind that
are today cancelled
and that'll do it for us today i'll talk
to you actually on monday there will be
no show tomorrow but this time it's not
my fault the the whole company is is
closing down tomorrow so everybody's off
tomorrow it's not just me just so you
know
and uh i'll talk to you on monday have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the benton shapiro show the
bite administration continues to happy
talk its way through recession democrats
try to prop up extremists in republican
primaries while decrying their supposed
rise and the view has to back off its
lander of tpusa that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen